tengámoslo claro el mundo nunca antes
había estado mejor gracias en gran
medida a la globalización cada vez hay
menos guerras la pobreza se está
reduciendo con fuerza y todos los
parámetros referentes a la calidad de
vida mejoran no claro de forma uniforme
pero si bajo una perspectiva global sin
embargo contra todo pronóstico en el
mejor momento de la humanidad muchos
países occidentales han decido rebelarse
y apagar la antorcha de la apertura y el
entendimiento entre los pueblos en
europa por ejemplo los partidos de
extrema derecha están sembrando el
desconcierto de pene en francia
o hoffer en austria son buenos ejemplos
de una ola que también recorre finlandia
dinamarca alemania o hungría entre otros
y que incluso ha sido responsable en
gran medida de la victoria del presi en
reino unidos
movimiento que explota el miedo a lo
diferente aun cuando vivimos en
sociedades que cada vez son más seguras
de hecho como podemos ver un británico
de hoy en día tiene 135 veces menos
posibilidades de morir asesinado que su
homólogo en la edad media pero esta
corriente todos lo sabéis no es
monopolio de europa
donald drama ganado las elecciones en
eeuu con un discurso claramente
contrario a la globalización y la
inmigración a estas alturas del partido
la mejor pregunta que nos podemos hacer
es si no quien acaso algún país
desarrollado que siga apostando por la
apertura pues siglos hay y hoy vamos a
hablar de uno de sus abanderados
ver turismo de canadá en todo el año
2016 canadá habrá admitido a más de
300.000 nuevos inmigrantes cerca del 1%
de su población una proporción mayor que
la de prácticamente cualquier otro país
grande y desarrollado y ojo no es una
apuesta nueva lleva en vigor más de dos
décadas el resultado es que hoy uno de
cada cinco canadienses ha nacido en el
extranjero un porcentaje que casi
duplica al de eeuu o españa por ejemplo
y que la verdad sea dicha es que esto no
ha conllevado ninguna desgracia nacional
todo lo contrario y los canadienses son
los primeros en saberlo según un estudio
del prestigioso en byron yx institute la
inmensa mayoría de los ciudadanos
prácticamente ocho de cada diez
consideran que la inmigración es buena
para la economía y que representa la
mejor forma de enfrentarse a problemas
tan importantes como el envejecimiento
demográfico si lo pensáis tiene bastante
sentido el factor trabajo es el recurso
productivo más importante así que por
qué impedir que crezca en el marco de
una economía dinámica qué tiene de malo
que haya más personas dispuestas a
trabajar
montar empresas oa formarse o
especializarse de hecho es algo bueno
un año de justin crudo en octubre de
justin crudo se convirtió en primer
ministro al derrotar contra todo
pronóstico el conservador stephen harper
quien había ocupado el poder durante
prácticamente 10 años desde entonces la
agenda política ha estado dominada por
el empeño del gobierno en profundizar en
políticas aperturistas y pro
globalización el propio crudo un hombre
de izquierdas se ha convertido en todo
un paladín en favor del libre comercio y
la movilidad de las personas en su
primer año de mandato ha firmado el
acuerdo de libre comercio con la unión
europea y ha confirmado la adhesión de
canadá al pp en un solo año
canadá ha forjado relaciones de libre
comercio con cerca del 60% de la
economía mundial
y ojo crudo ahora quiere hacer algo
similar con china
decidimos iniciar discusiones
exploratorias con vistas a un acuerdo de
libre comercio entre canadá y china- y
respecto a la inmigración y el gobierno
canadiense está en la misma línea
incluso se ha fijado como meta aumentar
el número de inmigrantes que reciben
cada año en un 50%
canadá necesita más inmigrantes
necesitamos la llegada de sangre más
joven para mantener nuestras economías
en marcha dada esta vocación no puede
sorprendernos y canadá este siendo uno
de los países más comprometidos a la
hora de facilitar la llegada de los
refugiados sirios desde que crudo es
primer ministro khan ha dado acogida a
más de 33 mil sirios e incluso durante
su primer mes de gobierno el propio
primer ministro se acercó al aeropuerto
de toronto para darles la bienvenida al
país que diferencia con lo que está
ocurriendo en españa
la política migratoria
en canadá la inmigración no es libre
está regulada más de lo que a los
miembros de este canal nos gustaría pero
la cuestión es que no se trata ni mucho
menos de que no exista ningún requisito
administrativo sino de que no
consideremos nunca como delincuentes a
quienes quieren venir a trabajar a
emprender y a forjar una vida en
nuestros países y ese es precisamente el
éxito de canadá un país que se jacta de
buscar ciudadanos y no inmigrantes
temporales desde 1967 existe un sistema
de puntos que tiene en cuenta la
cualificación la experiencia las
habilidades profesionales o la capacidad
para hablar inglés o francés de la misma
forma que también se da preferencia a
los profesionales demandados por las
empresas de la pisa direccionada con
méxico
sierra eliminada terminada finita caput
la tendencia de los últimos años pasa
por agilizar y facilitar estos
procedimientos pero la cuestión más
importante no es ésta sino el
reconocimiento social y el marco de
integración a los inmigrantes que existe
la propia carta de derechos y libertades
de canadá ojo reconoce el concepto de
patrimonio multicultural en este país
existen
sólidas políticas para favorecer la
integración que por cierto pasan casi
siempre por animar a los recién llegados
a no perder su identidad cultural y a
considerar la diversidad como un factor
enriquecedor por ejemplo en los propios
colegios públicos es fácil encontrar
clases impartidas en español o en
ucraniano y desde luego los resultados
avalan estas políticas en la última
década canadá ha crecido más que eeuu
alemania o reino unido y ha consolidado
un nivel de vida muy elevado ahora ya
podemos entender por qué la web
canadiense de inmigración se colapsó a
las pocas horas de conocerse que trump
sería el nuevo presidente de los eeuu
que the economist le dedique portadas
como esta
incluso nuestros amigos de ex patishtán
cuentan como el tráfico desde eeuu se ha
disparado en los últimos días desde
luego que nada dista mucho de ser un
modelo perfecto pero frente a las
corrientes nacionalistas y populistas
este país muestra como la alternativa de
la libertad es deseable porque amigos la
clave está en hacer mejor las cosas no
en encerrarse al mundo tal y como
defienden políticos como donald trump
bueno ahora te toca a ti crees que la
inmigración entrena tantos problemas
como afirman algunos no prefieres acaso
vivir en sociedades abiertas y diversas
como la canadiense espero vuestras
respuestas y desde luego si aún no
sabéis suscritos a visual político
podéis hacerlo ahora pulsando en este
botón y también os invito a darle a like
si os ha gustado esta alternativa a las
políticas de donald trump un saludo y
hasta la próxima amigos